hombre
adentro de lunes a viernes en este
comedor vicentino misioneros y
voluntarios preparan raciones de comida
para la gente necesitada pedimos al
señor que bendiga estos alimentos pero
la crisis que trajo el kobe ha hecho
esos religiosos redoblar esfuerzos y
afuera decenas de personas hacen filas
desde el mediodía en espera de recibir
los alimentos que manda el gobierno de
la ciudad a este comedor javier coordina
la recepción de los platillos y es él
quien hace la entrega de las 280
raciones aumentó a 400 acciones ya que
había gente desempleada sobre todo viene
mucha mamá soltera de corazón
en el chico más de un millón de personas
han perdido su empleo durante la
pandemia ya este comedor en el centro de
la ciudad ya no llega alguien en esa
situación
eladio es veterinario y también para le
obras pero el confinamiento afectó su
centro de trabajo por ello viene aquí
porque manda mi fuente de ingreso mayor
era la del archivo del asentamiento por
la pandemia no cerraron ahora estoy
esperando para poder iniciar de nuevo
cuenta mi vida actividad como
investigador a nueve kilómetros al
cliente la historia y se repite con un
restaurante de antojitos mexicanos como
el comedor vicentino a este restaurante
comenzó a llegar no sólo gente en
situación de calle sino también víctimas
del desempleo
diego adrián de 20 años perdió su
trabajo cuando se confirmó el poder
judicial
de limpieza limpiaba la turbina
[Música]
aquí también aumentaron las raciones que
regalan diariamente y procuran que nunca
se vaya a alguien sin recibir algo de
comida al segundo trimestre del año el
porcentaje de personas en pobreza
laboral fue de 48.1 por ciento aunque
instituciones como el consejo nacional
de evaluación de políticas de desarrollo
estiman que la pandemia aumentará hasta
en 10 millones más las personas en
pobreza por ingresos